[Musique]
je vous parle beaucoup de smartphones
savoir quel smartphone choisir si et saï
saï je vous parle assez peu
d'applications j'ai décidé de changer un
peu ça et de vous présenter des
applications vous parlez de pleins
d'applications diverses et variées à
découvrir que ce soit sur ios ou sur
android et on va commencer aujourd'hui
par les sept applications les plus
stupides et croyez moi j'ai trouvé
quelques petites perles sur ios mais
avant toute chose si vous êtes nouveau
sur cette chaîne et si vous me
connaissez pas et bien je vous invite à
nous rejoindre parce qu'on est quand
même de plus en plus nombreux et de plus
en plus nombreux et ça c'est hypra cool
merci à vous je vous présente bien
évidemment toutes les nouveautés
smartphone non connectés des tablettes
des ordi je vous explique comment les
utiliser comme les acheter au meilleur
prix
il ya beaucoup d'astuces beaucoup de
chance de partager et va y avoir encore
de plus en plus donc si vous n'êtes pas
déjà bonne et faites les vous cliquez
c'est alors attendez je sais jamais
quand je regarde je aller je dis que
c'est la bonne tromper c'est là vous
cliquer sur s'abonner vous activer la
cloche pour recevoir toutes les
notifications comme ça vous serez
heureux une rolls à sa tante
on va donc commencer par la première
application est la plus stupide sur ios
première application je peux si vous
avez un animal de compagnie si vous avez
un chien et si vous arrivez à
communiquer avec votre chien mais si
c'est pas le cas il est une application
qui vous permet de communiquer avec lui
très facilement ses applications elles
s'appellent dogues translator alors je
sais pas si elle vous permet réellement
de communiquer avec votre chien ou si
c'est juste un coup de génie de
quelqu'un qui s'est fait une grosse pub
ce tapis là avec du contenu premium
entreprend vous allez parler à votre
chien mais par exemple vous voyez que
votre chien lève une patte voulu passer
un petit discours
voilà le chien ou pas et si vous voulez
vous parle à votre chien
et bien vous n'avez jusqu'à appuyé ici
coucou mon chien comment vas tu es ce
que tu as faim vous avez parlé de votre
chien ça l'a traduit donc vous avez
plein de petites choses la fois très en
colère
là il est en colère là il est de la pâte
il est content l'ice gâte l'oreille ben
vous avez deux pages comme ça il ya du
contenu premium a bien verrouillé pour
parer votre chien si vous voulez vous
dire oui car non c'est vraiment une
application stupide vous avais prévenu
deuxième application stupide c'est une
application qui s'appelle celebrity
voice qui vous permettra de mettre sur
votre visage la voie d'une célébrité
c'est absolument complètement stupide or
il ya un peu de publicité
bien évidemment c'est du contenu gratuit
vous choisissez une célébrité 20h20
choisir qui maintient les la voix de
donald trump faut parler qu'en anglais
uniquement
voilà c'est que l'anglais faudra vous y
faire allo iam de présidence
andretti states and i'll of monsieur
greu il change la voie à la météo il
comprend pas tout mais voilà c'est un
petit peu ridicule vous venez vous le
téléchargez vous le partager avec des
amis
c'est rigolo autres applications et pas
des moindres c'est stupide à yzeure
alors je te puis dans l'histoire ça vous
permet de prendre votre tête et d'avoir
des expressions complètement stupide ce
que vous faites vous cliquez sur start
fait un petit selphy regardez par
exemple là ça me met comment mettre ma
tête je fais sur ok je dois regarder
euros regarder à gauche
regardez à droite fermez les yeux tirer
la langue
montrer les dents souris faire une
grimace
et voilà ça vous fait une tête
absolument complètement stupide et au
site vous pouvez toucher un élément de
visage par une volt langues sales change
touché à un oeil salle change ça joue ça
le ferme en février si absolument
complètement ridicule vous récupérez les
photos vous les partagez vous l'avez dit
c'est l'application qui est complètement
stupide autres applications un peu
stupides ces douze jours 20 heures
ça veut dire 'est-ce que vous préfériez
faire ça au plus tôt ça c'est un jeu
qu'on fait souvent entre amis
et là vous pouvez jouer c'est le fameux
tu préfères alors là tu préfères les
fraises les framboises les fraises faire
un rêve heureux qui te laisses triste au
réveil faire un cauchemar dont le réveil
de soulager le cauchemar glace boulot
chocolat glace à la vanille chocolat
regarder ton examen passer de mauvaises
vacances à passer de mauvaises vacances
être borgne avoir un troisième oeil en
plein milieu du front un troisième raid
va vous comprenez un peu l'idée c'est
complètement ridicule ça sert à rien
vous avez d'autres applications qui est
un peu d'acide et là c'est le fast and
furious corps pour trouver notamment
chez combiné vous devez voter entre deux
propositions patrie famille famille
queue de cheval chillon tête cheval noël
nouvel an
noël pasta pizza pasta cigare cigarette
ni l'un ni l'autre
moi j'aime et cigare dormir travailler
travailler n'est pas l'ex feu népal
bollywood hollywood hollywood combes of
plutôt content rugby foot plutôt rugby
voyez l'idée donc là c'est plutôt rigolo
deux applications qui sont un peu
stupide qui peuvent vous divertir et qui
reste un peu dans l'air du temps autre
application qui est un peu what the fuck
c'est l'application viber à tort qui
pour moi ne remplit pas également son
rôle c'est de la vibration on vous dit
c'est pour faire des massages fait
vibrer votre téléphone
ce nom un certain rythme pour faire des
massages ouais donc vous appuyez et ça
se met à vibrer pour venir ensuite
changé de mode vous avez soit le mode
briçois le mot de choeur sur le mall
impulsion vous peut augmenter la vitesse
de vibrations ça c'est uniquement un
mode premium et puis vous avez d'autres
modes également dans le mode tsunami
kalika ce volcan cascades et pour les
avoir bien évidemment il faudra payer
c'est complètement stupide et surtout ce
qui est stupide c'est de cacher le sens
puisqu'on est plus sur nos fonds de
vibromasseurs là dessus que de
vibrations de lutte dépenser au truc je
peux si vous connaissez quand j'étais
gamin il y avait là redoutent catalogue
papier et vous vous retrouviez avec des
godemichés et on vous le vendez comme
des masseurs de joux voilà donc ça c'est
un peu la même chose c'est un peu
déguisés mais ça me fait suffisamment
rigoler autre application c'est
l'application qui s'appelle bd live qui
vous donne en fait la date de votre mort
vous répondez à un questionnaire et
c'est assez précis déjà vous pouvez
importer les datas de votre montre fhd
déjà fait ça lui permet d'avoir des
vraies informations sur vous c'est un
peu flippant fait et vous continuez avec
des questions date de naissance ok ça
c'est ma date de naissance votre
alimentation normale pas très bonne ou
alors vraiment très très bonne pour moi
c'est pas vraiment très très bon jeu
moins fluide et fois bon qu'on la forêt
change un petit peu ça est-ce que vous
fumez ou pas non je ne fume pas est ce
que vous buvez ou pas une ou deux fois
par jour ouais ça arrive de temps en
temps les jeunes de votre famille c'est
pas terrible chez moi
qu'est ce que vous faites de l'exercice
oui tous les jours votre niveau de
stress chez moi il est quand même
relativement élevé 80 c'est pas un âge
nous végétons 79
j'ai fait des changements voilà ça me
rassure un peu mais bon voyez c'est
qu'un petit peu mal au crâne et au surf
et une dernière pour la route c'est les
petites bulles convient éclaté avec
votre doigt congrès du papier bulle que
vous recevez des colis pour toujours un
malin plaisir à venir les éclater et là
vous pouvez venir les écouter c'est en
fait je pense un peu un antistress et
j'adore ça même là dessus est ce un peu
frustrant parce que des fautes arrive
pas mais même là dessus a bien fou c'est
le truc complètement neuneu
hier par péter l'écran de l'iphone mais
voilà ça c'est une application
complètement stupide mais ça soulage
je vais continuer les éclater voilà
voilà pour ces quelques applications
stupide dit moi si ce format vous
intéresse que je vous parle de
différentes applications là je vous
parle d'applications stupides ne vous
parlera également d'application qui vous
rendront réellement service dans la vie
de tous les jours aujourd'hui on
concentre sur iphone non pas grave
d'android bien évidemment dont je vous
invite à vous abonner s'est pas déjà le
cas et bien évidemment à mais c'est un
joli pouces et puis si vous avez des
suggestions des idées de vidéos sur
différentes applications vous démarquer
en bas gérer piocher dans vos idées
et puis vous ferez dévié au-dessus sur
ce je l'embrassé on a beaucoup d'amour
et on se retrouve demain pour continuer
à parler de teck portez vous bien prenez
soin de vous 10 2010 châu
car
[Musique]
un an
pratique
aucun